you've done a million things in your
life
and been very successful a bunch of
young folks listen to this
ask for advice from successful people
like you
uh if you were to give advice to uh
somebody you know an undergraduate
student or some high school student
about uh pursuing a career
in computing or just advice about life
in general is there
some words of wisdom you can give them
so i think you come back to change
and you know profound leaps happen
because people are willing to believe
that change is possible
and that the world does change and
are willing to do the hard thing that it
takes to make change happen
and whether it be implementing a new
programming language or implementing a
new system or
playing a new research paper or
designing a new thing moving the world
forward in science and
philosophy whatever it really comes down
to somebody who's willing to put in the
work
right and you have the the work is hard
for a whole bunch of different reasons
one of which is
um you uh
it's work right and so you have to have
the space in your life in which you can
do that work which is why going to grad
school can be
a beautiful thing for certain people um
but also there's a self-doubt that
happens like you're two years into a
project is it going anywhere
right well what do you do do you just
give up because it's hard
well no i mean some people like
suffering um
and so you plow through it the the
secret to me is that you have to love
what you're doing
and and follow that passion because
if when you get to the hard times that's
when you know if you
if you love what you're doing you're
willing to kind of push through and
um this is really uh hard because
it's hard to know what you will love
doing until you start doing a lot of
things
and so that's why i think that
particularly early in your career it's
good to experiment
do a little bit of everything go go take
the the survey class on
you know for the first half of every
class in your upper division
you know lessons and um just get
exposure to things because certain
things will resonate with you and you'll
find out wow i'm really good at this
i'm really smart at this well it's just
because it works with the way your brain
and when something jumps out i mean
that's one of the things that
people often ask about is like well
i think there's a bunch of cool stuff
out there like how do i pick the thing
like uh yeah how do you how do you hook
in your life how did you just hook
yourself in and stuck with it
well i got lucky right i mean i think
that many people
uh forget that a huge amount of it or
most of it is luck
right so um let's not forget that um
so for me i fell in love with computers
early on because i'm
they they spoke to me i guess uh
what language did they speak basic basic
um but the uh but then it was just kind
of following a set of logical
progressions but also
um deciding that something that was hard
was worth doing and
and a lot of fun right and so i think
that that is also something that's true
for
many other domains which is if you find
something that you love doing
that's also hard if you invest yourself
in it and add value to the world then it
will mean something
generally right and again that can be a
research paper that can be a software
system that can be
a new robot that can be like there's as
many things that that it that can be but
a lot of it is like real value comes
from doing things that are hard
and that doesn't mean you have to suffer
but um it's hard i mean you don't often
hear that message
we talked about this last time a little
bit but i i it's one of my
fav not enough people talk about this
it's uh it's beautiful to hear a
successful person
well in self-doubt and imposter syndrome
and these are all things that
successful people suffer with as well
particularly when they put themselves in
a point of being uncomfortable which
i like to do now and then just because
it puts you in learning mode
like if you wanna if you wanna grow as a
person put yourself in
a room with a bunch of people that know
way more about whatever you're talking
about than you do
and ask dumb questions and guess what
smart people love to teach often not
always but often
and if you listen if you're prepared to
listen if you're prepared to grow if
you're prepared to make connections
you can do some really interesting
things and i think that a lot of
progress is made by
people who kind of hop between domains
now and then because they bring
uh they bring a perspective into a field
that nobody else has if people have only
been working in that field themselves
you